let's rock and roll guys good to go yep
lockdown Monday lockdown Monday guys
asleep daddy behind Monday it's leave
daddy behind Monday and lockdown Monday
we fresh from San Antonio / Austin where
I went to look for some property very
happy with what I saw could have a ranch
now here's the thing daddy's not going I
don't think you're out of your [ __ ]
mind
well let me see he gets it take you
snail ends leaving and then you're in I
gotta get the kids and the ax to move to
and that's good no listen what happens
in California what happens in all these
progressive states Seattle Portland Los
Angeles and all these progressive things
is that I'm all about you know not and
I'm against police brutality but if you
want to [ __ ] start like look at New
York City de Blasio that [ __ ]
socialist is not behind a police
department in hot now yeah as Austin's -
what happened - shut down I know but but
but murder about shootings are way way
up and [ __ ] New York and it's going
back to what it was in the [ __ ] 80s
and 90s and I remember it very well so
it seems to me that all these super
progressive states can't control their
homeless situations their taxes go way
up
I get [ __ ] all for my taxes [ __ ] all but
I can save how much in taxes is how much
cheaper yeah and and and and I get
better schools yeah I'll go there I'll
go there and more land and and my dollar
goes twice as far why the [ __ ] wouldn't
I go to start up the whole team and play
on the field but but you know let but
I'll let the socialist States and you
know their thing yep for sure super
serious we could buy bulls I would like
to buy a bull start riding could milk
cows first of all you start on a baby
bull now you get a baby bro you learn
you learn the baby you got to have you
got to have a groin pad because your
balls are gonna get crushed so what I
suggest for ease it with the way I do it
is I take a rope and I tie my dick and
balls
straight up cinch it onto my belly
button because you can't have them down
there cuz you're gonna fall and you're I
got low-hanging balls and you just gotta
make sure that the Bulldog hit daddy's
lids his new lids that's true too so
I'll wear a face mask now listen your
wear a helmet if my boat let's stick to
my balls for a second as if I come off
and one of my bones goes over here and
then I land back on it huh I got a bag I
got a kid I got a pancake not now we
grow with the baby bull as he grows we
grow as riders the casino we're riding
Ralphie there you go he's a full-blown
there you go giant now my buddy Bob he
decided he wanted to do a TV show where
he did all kinds of danger and he
learned very quickly the problem with
that is he get injured now he got on he
went to a bull riding thing got on a
pull and they said let's start you on a
horse on a bucking bronco let's not -
the horse was whatever well he goes he's
a very athletic strong guy and he goes I
got it I've ridden hard he said I can
break a horse he says the guy the guy
goes you can because sure is he's a
macho guy gets on the horse and the
horse goes the horse goes oh you're on
me I don't like it I'm gonna go this way
and then I'm gonna go that way my head
and I'm gonna knock out all all of these
teeth so he came back with a torn groin
and no teeth no I'm not talkin Branca
homeboy we're gonna buy a little baby
boys you've got long knives out with him
that's right we're gonna grow with him
ride them we ride them
I want a bullets a friend probably
wolves when they got balls
you never know they're rather
unpredictable oh that guy's cute as [ __ ]
oh I like that hair he thinks the baby
goats are his Oh
he's super and protects them dude how
much did you love Hotel Emma oh I loved
it we just lost lighting guys no you
know what I look good yeah the way this
is real AMOLED you think we got the neon
that's me I owed a pop it's not the
light that makes you look old
coz I'm in the same light really it's
just life I mean 53 years a son make you
look old I was in the Sun today what for
a bike ride this morning oh let the wind
blow back my hair yeah well put a lock
on you liked Hotel Emma though huh papa
they let you down
so Hotel a mom is one or more beautiful
places I've been ever and and I don't
know if you know this but they're gonna
tear that that brewery down and put
a Walmart distribution center is place
and something that the guy who runs the
whole hotel and some guy said that a to
an architect and I mean the designer
came in and said uh uh uh well buy this
[ __ ] thing he had a lot of money from
his ham dogger scared me I know oh no
not now oh well [ __ ] no that was the
idea oh no sure it's a gem yeah [ __ ]
yeah not like you're gonna tear it down
turtle whoa no no no no though that'd be
a crime it being high well yeah I would
chain myself to the front door it would
be an architectural crime now hippies
chained themselves they like oak trees I
would chain myself to the front door
vemma in the row holding their sour
cough in the 50s in the 60s in New York
City they did do that they tore down all
kinds of places like that in favor of
waves Robert Moses wanted to create
what's called flow and he created all
these big impersonal buildings there was
architectural crime after architecture
how great was that place though it's
like an old tree in it cool it's like an
old tree it's one of a kind you know I
said it's like Shawshank Redemption if
it was in Pleasantville how's that oldie
time vibe everybody's like red
everything is everybody's red and
everything is considered everything is
consol like every color the the bathroom
and there's the best bachelor scene when
I build my house or if I get a house I'm
gonna ask them what exactly tiles
everything they used and do the exact
thing I'm hearing it's ridiculous yeah
it's incredible I love that stuff look
at that oh dude I might do my nuts we're
all up in that row you know what they
did for Papa they finally put a XXX one
in there hey I'm glad you the cables to
you on my show like I'm glad I included
you on my show and you got a suite and I
got a regular room that's cool we know
why right why is Hotel Hellmuth my hotel
dude
they booked me I was tech me more the
headliner
well duh but it's oh no you're it's
Martin this el lol doesn't book your
hotel Bubba yeah but you could have
booked for me
hey [ __ ] sweet - that's the second
time you've done that
well no this on my show they upgrade me
huh they upgrade me no you're friends
with the owner and you couldn't say
hey get my boy in there but you let me
sit on the floor I can't I can't
that's my room I you don't get that room
I get a room - no papa yeah yeah so you
and your brother get the Suites
Jay didn't get a suite he's not a
regular roaster just you yeah there's
only one suite my hotel you didn't know
about that what Delta I came along
you welcome where else do we do that at
uh Houston uh he's dead um that was a
bad hotel anyway Houston place but hotel
I'm it there's nothing worse than bad
hotel I'm not saying the hotel I'm doing
the Airbnb is unless it's like a minor
idea much better idea um doesn't nasty
Oh hit the sour coffee sour I talked the
owner this morning he emailed me like
how would you stay everything up to par
blah I said nah you got the best hotel
in the world I love everything about
what you have sour coffee yeah
but he goes we do get complaints he goes
people who they love it or they hate it
yeah I went just offer a dark roast
though yeah exactly have have to have
two beers light and dark are everything
can't be sour [ __ ] we can't find a dark
- bummer
yeah cuz that one coffee shop that's
nearest we're gonna get there bean throw
them out local it's so bad full I'm
sorry I'll do spectacle but also do
better
I mean why tried that coffee it was so
sour I had it wife I hope they're
listening cuz they should actually do
thing about it I tasted it it was so
citrusy so Center some people like that
but for the regular drinker like me who
loves like a little bit I want some
chocolate once it was iced tea like
lemonade sour misty I had to throw it
away I took two sips and I was like I
can't drink this I'd rather drink
[ __ ] whoo that's not how to drink
that's not gonna make coffee it's not -
it's just not they said that's like
gonna shoplift those real light beans ha
ha because more caffeine though I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm here for flavor Bubba
yeah you you you can make money
sometimes with that because people well
they do and caffeine rush yes the
hipster movement I guess I don't know
yeah he goes yeah we get a lot of people
either love it or hate it I'm like what
do you just offer both cover both bases
yeah and also black rifles in San
Antonio have black rifle good door that
I thought they were in a salt lake no
they're renovating well their
distributions out of Salt Lake City but
their main like my boy Matt all them
they all live in funny kind of the show
you know what they probably takes me but
I forgot to take back oh hey Matt best
you can text me - not your friend but
you know oh he's as much my friend as
he's your friend
you think I don't know but he uh yeah
they're in San Antonio hmm the other
ones who introduced me in hotel ama
because I flew out there to shoot some
content for black rifle and they put me
up there I was like black top [ __ ] Wow
oh well yeah but but you think Hotel
image would just connect with them and
offer the beans
I would imagine Oh drama black rifle
your next-door neighbor's ditch the
local spot and get with the beans baby
black rifle is a good name for it - I
like it black rifle it's intense but you
can just call whatever it's the only
thing I might be a little intense
you call whatever yeah yeah yep
I went on a bike ride this morning I
told you right yep yeah Cruiser where'd
you buy credit Bettis it's down down
down a beach and it was very empty how
many bones did you hit all of them I hit
all the bums well I live in Venice now
for now and buy a needle or well I've
been in Venice for 25 years as you know
off and on but almost all on and it's
the worst I've seen it it's it's just
well Skid Row and ranan Skid Row and but
thank you politicians and it seems that
they really know what they're doing but
I pay crazy taxes and I live with
homeless people just across the street
the [ __ ] and you can hear them screaming
and [ __ ] on your front door and you can
hear and you can smell it and because
it's it the trash is crazy
so okay that's that's it and you go to
Sacramento and you say stuff and they're
like nah sorry you looks frustrated
antsy Pelosi you know what's frustrating
is we're gonna leave right we're gonna
leave them like [ __ ] you Newsome and
he's like see ya
well it's almost like they're airline
you know like no it's not that though
cuz I'm gonna take
have you seen a lot of the companies
that are leaving though it's a big
problem for California because what
happens is well your tax base Falls and
the people get hurt other people that
don't deserve to get hurt which are the
middle class class or are working hard
working people because what happens is
as business exodus from California see
this it's more troubling than you can
see this doesn't it's more and more
businesses are leaving a home there you
go Brian 1800 companies left California
in the year there you go
Texas no more destination for companies
thank you now what does that tell you
about on stage on it I'm moving to Texas
they all cheer they wait don't tell
anybody that was true I don't want a lot
of Californians come out and voting for
liberal policies will also they [ __ ]
rule in that state too and I'm liberal
I'm a libertarian I just mean big
government taxation and [ __ ] [ __ ] you
what's going on my Jets are a little hot
somebody call my dad's please what
happened Bubba I don't know I'm just I
just I want to go to Austin no I was
just biking and I was just around a
bunch of hope like my city got above me
my city of Los Angeles
I don't recognize and maybe I'm just
upset about this kovat thing though
you're still upset about Kovac I'm just
upset about how to pass I know they got
another two weeks of crying wolf and
everything's up but the death rates all
the way down the invention like all
right we got well currently NPR for the
first time admitted that it's not as
deadly as they've been saying it is so
it's all over they literally did the
fair poorness two more weeks
you think Sal oh there's all these
outbreaks all these outbreaks but
where's the death where's all the death
the death is lower than ever every every
Sunday that when they report every son
it's lower and lower lower lower
but cases here lower lower death what do
you do if beliefs like it like the Gavin
Newsome and Garcetti want to crash the
economy right so I'm sure that they also
I think there's a lot of Pat like
pressure to keep it closed because of
liability and all that stuff I don't
know I don't know they're getting a
public health officials are retiring I
mean are resigning because they're
getting death threats and stuff I mean
it's it's not easy for them either but
you know but also that's what you get
you know yeah I don't know if even hot
today dude
some bums no I don't want to hurt any
bumps because there's no they're
mentally ill or they're drug-addicted in
there let me think you see these people
are just they are not they should be in
a hospital or they should be in a
treatment center not on the [ __ ]
Street so you bet so it's had a little
bit of blow me problem you know I grew
up there never like this
Venice had rough crime and all that
Shimer and all but damn
did you damn well where you're at chin
that's [ __ ] bum central yeah heart of
downtown Oh downtown still crazy yeah
crazy everywhere well Skid Row that's a
10-6 get roads just ridiculous but even
just and the regular is it's it's all
everywhere everywhere yeah and they're
violent too now like I know how Venice's
but they're violent in LA the punch
people lie no matter no where they're
crazy it's not all their course like see
me blue eyes was saying he's like you
don't realize because you know he lives
in LA for a while and then he lives in
Vegas he's on the outskirts he's like
you don't realize how bad the homeless
problem is do we go elsewhere
yeah you really don't see it man yeah
that's what we shoot about the outskirts
of Austin were like I'm getting older so
suburb living sounds real good to me
you know but no yeah I think sometimes
your your eyes I said this friend who
was a designer and he said the most
amazing thing he goes I just had this
place hurts my eyes
because I I'm to always fixing things as
I Drive around and I think that's what
happens when you see all that sort of
degraded you know humanity and yo
certain Venice though dude yeah and I'm
like you're in Venice yeah like you're
in the heart of retiring yeah it's just
that like that's bad that you want out
that's what they do that the Venice yeah
it's so got charm there's still
something to it yeah you'd be fine no
matter what it's just better for my kids
man so if if New York if Manhattan was
the best for my kids I'd move to
Manhattan I honestly see no downside to
moving to Texas especially when you got
kids your age no are you kidding me but
our football field
my football field and play every Sunday
Bryan gonna come over gonna be the
all-time quarterback there guys
jadynn move out there I want to drop
back yeah how that hike yeah you you
know I have could drop back oh yeah
[Music]
reminds me that scene in Longest Yard
with Nick with that reminder that scene
then while you started with Nick totora
he was why can i play card I guess here
let me tell you this like throws the
ball crazy goes there sit down shut up
my footwork is stupid
yeah dude we could have freaking Sunday
football days barbecuing well dude
barbecue non-stop son I'll get a belly
big old belt would be cool cowboy hat
you in the pool so one cowboy hat the
whole timer in San Antonio the guy in
front row I know he was cool looking too
huh
yeah if you can pull a cowboy hat off
you can pull a cowboy half Luke Luke
Rockhold can fall for cowboy hat it's
hardly a soul Surfer no he pulls one off
throws I've seen pictures haven't mean
did this really he's a good-looking dude
but it's just not natural to him no
it'll be a natural oh look at that
no you mean this last Instagram post
Brian I swear to god I know you
definitely funny just you I mean
definitely follow him
let me see Luke Rockhold that's your
friend you can I love him I will follow
him now I don't follow Lulu you have
posted videos together hold on hold on
okay I swear I didn't see this I haven't
looked at my Instagram that's so funny
that's his is that really his first
answer yeah there's a snake in my butt
hmm that's what I think I don't follow
he's a cowboy that's where they we're
crazy and convenient huh what is that a
pack of cigarettes
that's huh looks like alcohol or
cigarettes it you still talk to my
twitch I'm all tight with it start to
lose all the fighting um he's done
fighting you're telling her I've fallen
mouthpiece Lantana you're falling oh I
didn't see that
that's hilarious I just
I was thinking about I said I saw a
picture of him I think on Polo I swear
to God I didn't see it I'm not lying I
that's just a crazy coincidence but he
he did a polo out of something or maybe
it was carlos condit who did it he looks
good with a cowboy hat on - no I swear I
really didn't I don't think I'm
following him dude New York am i yeah
cat just confirmed it yeah how do you
how do you find out where you go to who
you're following it says Luke Rockhold
yep you're only following 59 people so
Berlin it's pretty nice it's pretty easy
to follow in the nebula now Luke and
then it's Luke Rockhold yeah and if you
scroll through you'll see that you can't
see any pictures so if you can find that
picture am i it's possible to follow
somebody and not see their pictures
though right no you can get their
notifications never muted or
accidentally did not unfollow crystally
either that was mine no you follow Luke
right there see followers Luke Rockhold
oh dammit get young whoops bury you
probably just saw me cowboy oh no hi
yeah I saw him once but I'm not not this
but it's just funny that's his latest
[ __ ] thing yeah
he's getting everything uh-huh I'm glad
we solved that case that he's followed -
good good intensive work cat yeah thanks
it work good intensive work you know
intensive work there's a new doc on HBO
about the Golan's lady killer that dude
was so sadistic do you know what he used
to do fine economy I know with DNA but
they used to make he'd make a couple
he'd make the guy lie there I was with
I'm sorry on his back no no with a tea
without without with a tea set stomach
down I mean he put dishes on his back
and the dishes fell off you'd kill them
man he would rape the girl while you
rape the girl that the husband have
facedown dishes on his back if they fell
off he'd kill both of them although I
just stayed calm don't let the plates
move while your girl get raped
good guy I mean he's a [ __ ] man
that's sadistic [ __ ] and how about uh
our boy he was a cop by the way do you
know that how crazy is that he was a
police officer and that out yeah well
Patton Oswald you know his former wife's
the one who solved it and wrote the book
that's right yeah I love he's in the
documentary it's it's fascinating man
it's so good that's crazy and she died
she died of cancer cancer huh such a
butt and she didn't know she solved the
case
Jill you know she passed them then they
got salt damn so it you know patent laws
one it does the foreword for a book and
then he talks to his documentary how
they met and like how obsessed she was
with true crime stuff it's super
fascinating she found that [ __ ] got
him she was obsessed with the trial nuts
man I mean like raped over 80 women
murdered 10 or 15 people not student
after all this time and then they you
know they come from DNA doing like
ancestry.com and [ __ ] and then he's they
actually I think it's news today he's
gonna he's gonna accept the the verdict
he's guilty he admits like seven deer I
don't know what the [ __ ] he's just a
[ __ ] okay I got away with evil effort to
evil well this guy's [ __ ] terrible you
don't hear much about him too you know
she started talking about it just prior
to him it was all about the 13 counts of
first-degree murder so he murdered a lot
of people - oh yeah 50-plus rapes 13
murdered you think about it yeah the
Zodiac killer gets all the hype right
they may who visa bottom yeah
he didn't kill nowhere near as many
people talking here let's see
things weren't a mass you can protect us
he'll just shoot him in the [ __ ] head
biani let the homies rape oh yeah he's
gonna be in some trouble
the key blendable yeah got to do it's
beyond me
I've tried it it's not bad it's not good
for young me it's not good I believe
that no I believe it why do you say that
he has all these additives and it's like
it's for your body to problem isn't it
laughs you know laughs what's the hottie
the charge of murder of Charlene Smith
within the media Penal Code section 2 so
you know he raped teenagers mainly 2.2
12 year olds 13 year olds 14 or 15 year
old he's more fungus I think he's just
seeing guilty guilty
you think I'll sit this guy's on the
head but he got away with it like he got
away with he got away with Addie things
got a higher life now he's whatever 80
something he's be gonna die any day
anyway so now you catch him like he got
a bomber and that's a bummer about like
political leaders like Pol Pot who
killed a million people in in Vietnam
and Cambodia I'm sorry and he was just a
monster he created what's called the
killing fields and he died of old age in
Thailand Villa yeah and said my
conscience is clear I was trying to
start a revolution you know but there's
no show path so there's like that kid
from who created the Silk Road who did
the yeah is the black market drug
trading great I need the dark web the
dark yeah the dark web essentially you
got to life since he's 26 years old yet
to life scent yeah yeah Ross Ulbricht
yeah Stevie talks damn yeah I know I'm
starting to see you about on the plane
super fascinating yeah I looked into it
like holy [ __ ] what a story
Ted Pirate Roberts I guess they did exam
I guess because there was major drug
trafficking and even hits like I said he
ordered like five hits on people he did
yeah he did yeah well then you gotta go
to jail that's why I said to Stephen
seems like well they can't prove that
like now if you're there order them if
you ordered did you know how the
fascinations you'll have a
got it - is you know they didn't know
who people were on there really so they
had an undercover agent pretend he was
he took over somebody's account so they
arrested one guys account he all that
information so undercover cop pretended
he was that account it was a kid we got
a problem he's like alright get rid of
music right semi 200 grand I'll take
care of your problem which was the hit
and this supposing Ross sent that money
then again they kept sent him up this
person this person so he ordered like
five hits for hire well I mean that's
that's the products that mean a lot guys
murder five people he is in but all for
all he knows those murders were done
because all it was all fake the cops do
yeah they're good they're good they're
not dumb it's like so so my boy this
friend of Mines nephew got put in jail
he was dealing drugs and he goes he goes
yeah but they told me that they they
were just want to talk to me a my buddy
who you know goes hey dude
feds lie sometimes to criminals when
they're trying to catch them that's what
they do sometimes because you're doing a
major crime it's part of police work
you're [ __ ] idiot so he went to jail
yeah huge balls he was all set up by
these guys he went to like a like cafe
in San Francisco and they're like y'all
wait from the long a certain thing
because if you don't log into that a
host computer he's so good with
computers that app will shut down like
you could no one can ever access it and
he knows this so it's what these feds
did they got him there he's talking to
the February thinks it's another guy in
like ice under some and he goes hey I
need you jump on this count confirm so
they knew that Hugh was inside what they
need to see they had to fake feds
getting an argument behind him and as he
logged in you're heard argument turned
as he turned the feds grabbed his
computers because they knew it was open
and they kept it open arrested him and
they kept it open the whole time and
just download all uh all the data genius
and his argument was he's like well I
sold the company I said I'm not part of
I sold it years ago I'm not part of it
but then they have [ __ ] tat
takes a person goes the guy goes he's a
former owner something like built
another something like that and he goes
does anybody know he goes to people and
he goes wool [ __ ] that's not giddy OHS
don't worry they think I sold it kind of
[ __ ] I mean kind of [ __ ] it yeah but
I like talking with Stevie likes it I
get so Stevie telling about the storm
like that's [ __ ] up due to year like
opinions are awful for years and with
that source an El Chapo so I get a hold
on and all around the plane I'm research
on simple research simple background
search know I do I so was a to almost
three-hour plane ride I read the report
for two hours I Stevie here's why you do
we try killing five people
he's to offer his knowledge he thought
those people were murdered comes five
people wolves in his moment but in his
mind your who's down to Hillary I'll
kill her yeah you know he got the
kingpin rule if you run a drug
organization you're the kingpin you get
the [ __ ] books don't at you they made
him like the you know yeah
CVS no he never got charged there was
also sex trafficking on the dark web
there was no he's not dark web though so
his his thing wasn't that he's homegrown
no his Silk Road was drugs mainly drugs
and weapons
oh not never people said shopping okay
at the time was just drugs I think it
was used so be encrypted tech leakage he
could have used for all that so
eventually yeah yeah there was a weird
story about this really gorgeous model
in England who was kidnapped by these
she said Romanian or you know Albanian
sex traffickers and they were going to
they put an ad on on the web for to have
sex with her they were gonna force her
to have sex because she was like you
know really beautiful and kind of a
little bit famous and then the guy found
out she was a mother and he let her go I
remember this I thought she made it up I
don't know did she make it up cuz it
sounds made out it sounds like if you're
bad enough to kidnap a woman and put her
up on the dark web for you know [ __ ]
I thought it was fate abate remember we
felt it was fake yeah right abduction of
Chloe
ailing BAE's bears pastry model I had
traveled him and on
Italy for our fake photo shoot there she
was abducted by two individuals claim to
be members of a criminal organization
called the Black Death group all right
hold on the music what else does it
saying there on top both national from
the United Kingdom was convicted in a
Milan Court of the kidnapping and
sentenced to 16 years and nine months in
prison Wow as if June 2019 the trial of
a suspected accomplice his older brother
Michael her about remains in progress so
it is true yeah it was just fishy when
we first read it right yeah something
was just sounds so crazy I know [ __ ]
publicity stunts although later it
became clear from this way that she was
not involved Wow so me was just a ransom
email it was like a kidnapping really
[ __ ] strange man yeah it was funny
was Stevie's like did he I just mean him
used to write back and forth oh my god
that's such a shame dude I think that's
awful there hey
hey Stevie Vic killing 15 he was they
never proved that they actually threw
those a legal yeah cuz there he got him
for double life sentence so that I can a
waste taxpayers money on get him for
this why don't he was thrown it out I
mean I don't know I mean if they pull it
out they set it up though for where he
was actually paying the money and
correct yeah I mean I to God's knowledge
in his well that's that is murder but
you talk to Stevie and you talk was in
the kids mom was saying it's all fake
that was at him he was all set up this
was another guy was running they do this
all time when people want to kill their
spouses for insurance money or whatever
and they they get you they the cops will
get wind of it and they'll pose as a hit
man and they give you a chance they're
always say you sure you want to go
through with this they give you a chance
to back out when you don't they close in
on you they arrest you and oh but
sometimes it you know what's amazing
this one woman had it done she was she
only did a year in prison it's like how
are you doing here you should do [ __ ]
life to me he's a good-looking kid man
all right I mean I wouldn't say that I
would he looks like he looks like the
guy from I didn't talk
Ross Pattinson Robert Pattinson
Sanderson yeah looks like it
passing that kind of micro no what are
you talking about what do you do seen
Robert Patterson yeah I'm out of sit and
I've seen hi Vincent they lose the new
Batman well I don't agree with that I
mean I don't see that much of a
difference dude let's see that's Batman
dude bad they look similar
yeah looks like his little brother who
became a hacker yeah yeah a little
brother that never leaves the basement
there you good-looking kid yeah not bad
not what you expect from a hacker right
he's no Batman I'm not I'm not a master
criminal I guess you know well I don't
man I would say he's a master villain
no I'm saying dark he doesn't look like
a master oh no no no no but my field I
think is is like he couldn't he'd be an
ally for a government if he's that smart
can we use them for what's going on now
okay Houston I can say that's what I'm
saying instead of you know basically you
ruined this kid's world his life can we
use them as an ally they don't they
don't need him that they have a lot of
really smart
hackers you know I'm saying you can't
rely on someone like that also if you've
murdered if you've if you've tried to
mercy them either keep up the murders
the the thing I can't get over now if
you talk in spirit c-3 and like Sam
Tripoli and those guys they're gonna
tell you that he was all set up it's not
real yeah well that's not how the FBI
works initially I would imagine
wait Wyatt was Jared Leto I'm trying to
open it but it's not alone in here
something that's what I'm guessing he's
probably to play him because there's a
crazy story crazy crazy I just bought
the book there's supposed to be a really
New York Times best selling book - and
then you know Steve because he's friend
Steve you know the books like I guess
when he's hot killing people he's like
yeah [ __ ] killing me think he didn't
talk like that like well they have his
texture so yeah yeah be interesting to
see and the real story Ross Ulbricht but
dude he's never getting out of jail oh
dude he can't even there's no there's no
he's not up for parole Bubba it's to
life
this plus 40 years well you're never
getting out of jail do you know it's
heartbreaking they thought he was only
get 20 years I guess Stephen Stockton
he's like dude it's 20 years can you
imagine and then he goes in and he he
gives the you know the the judge this he
gets up and goes you know I've I know
I've done crime and you know I'm gonna
lose my middle you I'm gonna lose my
adult life don't let me lose my my old
man please give me the old man life and
a half and they're like yeah cool story
to life sentence plus 40 years he
thought is it going in it was it because
they were trying to make an example of
him or yeah cuz he's like the first [ __ ]
you remember this is 2008 2 and 10
that's a really loud yeah I get this
freaking test but he was the first like
crypto currency like all right you know
they made an example they may example
but he put it again the kingpin charge
because I don't you got masterminds on
there well some drugs without getting
caught but all that and also also what
else they're saying is how many people
Odie's on all the drugs I know but
that's not see that's I don't put that
on it no me neither I put that on he
create a platform and chooses to do
drugs and all that I don't put that on
I don't even put on him if he was this
entrepreneurial kid who figured out a
way to make money and move drugs
I think drugs should be legal cuz I
don't believe this war on drugs has been
very helpful but that's not the way
that's true what I'm saying is that I
give you 20 years given 20 years I would
be like those life sentences but now if
you're trying to kill five people it's
tough now I got a huge profit that's not
now now I'm like well you're [ __ ]
you're you that's the height of
immorality you're actually murdering
that's the hiccup who you can't murder
you can't try 200 inches one person
really file those people because you
know Stevie told me it's a bunch of
malarkey and they did throw it out but I
think see federal prosecutors allege
that uber get paid seven or thirty
thousand dollars and murder for hire
details starting at least five people
alleged the ledge because he threatened
yeah they threatened to out and
basically prosecutors believe no
contract killing occurred or actually
not charged in the trial in New York
photo with any murder for hire but
evidence was introduced at trial
supporting the allegations
the elegance the evidence that Albrecht
had commissioned murders was considered
by the judge in sentencing
Albrecht to life there you go and was a
factor in the second court to affirm the
life sentences a separate incident
against Albrecht in federal court in
Maryland on a single murder for hire
charge alleging that he he contracted to
kill one of his employees a former Silk
Road moderator this was prejudiced by
prosecutors in July 18 to 2018 after his
New York conviction since became final
so I don't think they want to pursue it
like what else where the gasps good god
I mean but that makes sense if you're
the judge and you're gonna go dude I
mean for whatever technical reason we
know that you did this because he's
looking at evidence that's that would be
my thing and it crazy though
nuts been so he made it first and was
made his own because he was like he was
in Austin he was like doing stuff and it
was was it successful and had no money
and had a girlfriend and then he came up
with this idea and critten and came up
with his own shrooms mm-hmm and sold
those he's again they sold fast and I
can't trace anything to me it's nothing
she opened it up so but the fear has
always been if someone to do this he
controls everything so the fair would
and you know he can't call the feds or
the cops like hey this guy took money so
the fear is they have all this
cryptocurrency in there let's say gets
up to 24 million well he has access to
all of it because any transaction he
take 10% but he was in you could see all
the transactions so the scare was if you
didn't trust them I'm sure people have
done before all the money gets in there
and then he takes in a run which
happened after he got charged another
one came up you know like Silk Road 2.0
and then others came up and then one got
up I think all the way to 18 million
they had 18 million like the whole thing
and they just dipped out and they never
found him so everyone lost their money
[ __ ] this cashed I know a guy who was
equipped on currency wanted a few first
guys to create cryptocurrency and he had
bodyguards with him all time because
they were afraid but I remember that guy
organized crime would kidnap him and
then you know for all the programs it
make sense because the kind of guys that
deal in cryptocurrency a lot of times
they're not then why cuz the only one no
in their moves I mean you know yeah you
got some rough dudes I don't know
anything about that world cryptocurrency
or the dark web or Silk Road well cuz
you're not a criminal I know but like
even if you took but again if you talk
to Jay like with the dark web and like
you you have to know so much stuff just
to gain access to get on there Jesus
just a game just you up there like know
all this like legalized ramming liens
yeah yeah I'm everyday know so I always
forget it exists there's a dartle web
but but even just like we're not even in
the [ __ ] realm but also how you so as
I joined the dark web Brendan like do
you have like a pass or is there an app
I downloaded I would you buy how would
you buy stuff on there too if it's like
krill you want to back crack you of
cocaine alright go yeah crypto get the
money then you send it you can't trace
it yeah they send it they send it
somewhere I mean if I was a cop I just
set those down and I don't [ __ ] know
what I do but they can trace like
because you have this in order to be
part of the club I don't help dark web
works they have no [ __ ] I'm talking
about but on Silk Road you have to
submit your driver license in like five
grand just to get in the club but then
you got another program and [ __ ] like
uploading what I'm out dude I don't need
drugs I'll go to the [ __ ] Venice to
get my drug yeah I'm also I'm not I'm
not looking to buy uranium from from a
Russian scientist yes I carry I get mind
trying to take over the world yeah I
know what the [ __ ] to do dude but it's
just like when I was reading up on
unlike the the work there's a whole
nother world when I even can sit we're
not even pardon out we're not we're not
even for not part of it but Cyberman
thought tick tock was confusing the dark
web is a big [ __ ] thing man
but even like trading like all this [ __ ]
it's like yeah I don't have never get
forums I don't goddamn you have to be
what's smart son of a [ __ ] leaving jump
into that world right now we're just
doing ice I think a lot of the foreign
intelligence services probably use it to
who knows man oh for sure but yeah like
hackers and sugar
who knows mm-hmm it's a whole goddamn
world of danger you gotta do your thing
right now it's 1:30 yeah she'll be here
in five minutes okay what are you doing
oh go get covetous I'll get one well I
think they can do it on the spot
they just swab you all they want to you
shall pay for it yeah well because uh
you go see my parents you're seeing them
this week this Friday
I don't know kopi now a lot of people
ask me why my hair is so thick and lush
and and then they see old pictures of me
and they go Brian your hair was really
thin and then they go do you get a hair
transplant and I go maybe maybe not the
point is it didn't take but I do take
him all the time wish you had this
earlier huh yeah because the only way to
actually the only proven way that I from
my research to stop your hair from
falling out is to take finasteride which
actually brings your hair back do not
case you get my lookit bronzes didn't
use hymns you stay there you go 66% of
men start losing their hair by the age
of 35 and they do yeah and once it goes
it goes yes but but but there is no
doubt that finasteride that which is
what hymns really is is is probably the
most measured effective idiot not just
probably it is the most afford and calm
a one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual illness for the dudes man no
snake oil pills or gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions back
by the Savio doctors online you connect
with them I did it answers your
questions man yep there you go stalk
over each other oh yeah go ahead dude
for Ames dot-com sighs fat K that's for
hems calm / fat K prescription requires
an online consultation with a medical
provider with that will determine if a
prescription is appropriate offer Val
only as prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information for him
stop /fa TK talk to me I'll whoop I know
you were
I know it's accurate we know it's got
crazy technology and thick-ass was
writing this morning and I thought about
you how far am I going cuz the app that
I'm using the app not not before whoop
but that I was using we go
oh you burn 1,400 calories I move with
yak cheaper nine hundred fat-ass oh well
thank you thank I pad thank you for that
cuz it tracks your strain your sleep
dude everything yeah
how much sleeves you get last thing do
you know I slept well you have no idea
that I don't know you're guessing I'm
taking the guesswork out start rocking
whoop dude whoop goes beyond tracking
steps and focus on something meaningful
on time outs train this is looking for
how active your heart is throughout the
day calculates that into how strenuous
your day is throughout your workouts
based on your recovery whoop provides
target strain goals which helps least a
more optimal training if you're a part
of the thick boy bike club this is key
man Lube automatically tracks workout so
you can focus just on your training
whoop has a built-in app feature that
allows you to track your strain from
training in real-time you monitor your
heart rate calories burn average heart
rate what your zone heart your heart is
in we're talking about strain your
workout sleep how much sleep are you
actually in there's nothing like it
maybe a five-day battery life so you can
charge it and in five days how about
it's waterproof daddy it's waterproof
want to swim with low-energy yep I don't
know what that means but it sounds
awesome
pretty frickin so we're gonna get woop
can you give them some some some money
off yeah man just download the app on
your device your phone all right then go
to whoop is offering you guys 50% off
with the code fighter at checkout go to
whoop that's wh ooo P calm enter the
code fighter at checkout you save 15%
off sleep better recover faster train
smarter optimize your performance with
whoop get it thick boys ah let's do some
current events buddy let's say you good
sounds good sounds good how about that
uh mean count got the Kovach test the
little note you just got swapped up
confident do well with the nasal swipe
no I don't do I don't like that cuz I
cuz when I broke my nose and had it like
redone yeah me too
ir dad to pack me and unpack me pack me
again I'm talking pack me again I'm pack
me I had complications I'm it was the
worst pain I've ever been so I
reminder that so I'm very squeamish I
don't like [ __ ] way up my nose so
literal that you should see this it's
not that bad yeah Oh actually I
[ __ ] though yeah it does heis
word she said it's like like eating a
bunch of wasabi yeah oh that's not too
bad it's pretty intervene on he goes
I'll take the masada he goes where for
your nose I don't want things up my nose
no no I thought it was instant results
no they hit their bodies I did were they
the blood yeah I don't have them that's
a thick and tough you had it the past
week or prior weeks hmm swapped 24 to 48
hours
there you go I got to see my parents
Friday they're 80 so if you have it
you're not gonna go huh my mother's so
funny my mother's like look I'm gonna
die of something so you know I just come
yeah my Dom saying my mom I think it is
you if you're older you don't want to
know you know you got to be very careful
so I'm gonna be social distancing for my
mom and dad so this past week a bunch of
voiceover actors came out and stepped
down from their roles if they were
playing black or biracial roles so Jenny
slay on the show big mouth actually
voices a biracial character and she
stepped down saying that it should be
played by a black actress instead Nick
Kroll also came out in support of this
and then the guy who voices what's his
name's Cleveland from Family Guy also
stepped down oh wow I don't agree with
any of it I think you're an actor and
you should be allowed to play anybody
you want I think a black person should
be able to play a white person in a
cartoon kind of black person with a
white person can a black person play an
Asian person can an Asian person play a
white person what are we [ __ ] talking
about if you're an actor and you're good
for the the actual part then it should
be colorblind it should be about it
should be about talent and humor and the
best person for the role and I don't
think color should play a role in it at
all but now since you're playing
identity politics on that side yeah what
the [ __ ] are you doing but this is
Hollywood this is the horseshit that
Hollywood does because they feel
helpless and they want to
part of a movement and they do this with
everything and I happen to know Jenny
slate and I know Nick Kroll and I like
those guys a lot I respect them and
Jenny's really telling and a great
person and so I'm not I'm not
criticizing her necessarily I don't
agree with her choice no and I don't
even agree with it as a gesture but
that's me our panel you make different
people can be upset if like okay and
they rewrite Cleveland as a white guy
and then that white guy still plays the
voice what about a woman who plays a
child can a woman play a child what are
we talking about here what what about a
large person who plays a dwarf is that
allowed or do you need a dwarf what are
you what are you talking about this is
this this is the kind of horseshit that
doesn't make the world less racist it
doesn't make that that doesn't do any
good it doesn't have any impact it's
just an empty popular gesture and this
is what happens everybody wants to be
yeah sweet we do Brennan's now going to
get and hiding that looks like a large
bag of piss
what there's a lot of stuff in there huh
how many how many rows are in that a lot
of steroids vitamin C b12 zinc pumpers
run down now you were squeamish about
needles you all right not at all yeah no
problems zero prompt than any of it did
I like no I don't even you have to sit
there for an hour 45 minutes I don't
ever want to see you get one of those
needle swipes again I look less of you
as a friend and a man you don't want you
my foxhole I was a bit of a baby she
went Jesus come on man but that tough
that's gonna sign out sign off on the
phone I love them huh now I can't see
any veins how you gonna find veins on
the big man never oh there you go you
got some veins old friends since they
have the best in the business
yeah well you definitely donor stelson
you're definitely now but you got some
veins Oh every nurse I've never seen
veins on you you're cute what is that
now blood pressure I just had a triple
americano before you
no fever 900 that tests your blood
pressure that's wild
never seen one huh huh hold on yeah no
it's too um call ways do the one with
thee
they still do this one's a pump yeah no
that's right a guy well when you go to
the doctor yes really yeah
I've only this one really how's his
blood pressure because he's a little
nicotine freak I do have it I've had two
triple Americanos this morning we had a
little scare with Brennan thought he had
high blood pressure turns out he doesn't
I just had a lot of nicotine in my body
yeah whiskey nicotine yeah Brendan go
and get a gonna get a check-up he's got
whiskey hers nicotine in the middle of
the day coffee
yeah sorry that's my whiskey bus all
right we drink whiskey you weren't
really drinking whiskey Antonia didn't
do any drinking I don't know I just
haven't drinkin I'm even yeah I like to
I want to watch this now we're gonna get
we're gonna tap ourselves vein alcohol
that up you can't look huh your fame
right um I don't want to flinch what's
that oh it's never comfortable to have a
needle stuck into your arm it's no I
don't enjoy now nobody enjoys that
little prick here I get IVs all time I
once had a nurse try seven times yeah I
know I do can you feel it going in your
body oh yeah yeah now really yeah you
got him a lot when you're fighting right
no no wait more now I've either illegal
now and there's these stupid well maybe
they're trying to get people not suck as
much weight or something no they think
it masks ladies you know I was just
thinking about her now the one uh one of
my biggest break one of the biggest
things I've done was a commercial for
wrangle right for what for Ringo oh yeah
the woodwork
Johnny javi and I did a very
country-western white accent and you
know that was my biggest be know thing
I'm Korean so how would that look that's
a sweet doesn't look bad
well how about the guys cause I'm an
actor the guy who does Abu on Simpson
just like 40 voices on yeah yeah you
have to step down as their boo it's like
it's ridiculous I I just think that I
just think there were actors and I don't
think it should be allowed to do that
don't think it's helping what's not
helping in the direction that I think
everybody wants so Brennan you know yes
that's so so George Floyd Rashard Brooks
these two guys were shot you know I mean
one guy was killed terribly executed
registrar Brooks more controversial but
but can if if these and I've said this
before I mean if you really care if
these corporations and Hollywood who
take responsibility if you guys actually
really care about it's like on Father's
Day weekend in Chicago Brennan a hundred
black people were shot though primarily
from other black people well well five
kids were killed eight kids were shot
so that's on one weekend in Chicago so
if you if you care and if you're serious
where were you what are you doing about
that and where is your outrage and why
is CNN not talking about that oh I see
and why is nobody talking about that but
you're talking about that one guy and
you're not talking about a hundred
people shot in Chicago we can go through
the list is it so but it again makes no
sense mainstream media's you know they
suck at the end I mean they don't tell
the truth what we get cold we do yeah
how has no one report on they're not
responsible people I don't I don't think
they're good people I think they're bad
people I think they're political
activists I don't know who they're for
I don't know what and I and I and I and
it's why CNN's ratings suck so badly and
I don't blame them I just you know and I
got you know with what's your take on
these toppling of all these monuments
it's like there's a process far back we
go well yeah yeah you took down they go
Theodore Roosevelt who is the first
person I think first president have an
african-american I think Frederick
Douglas in the in the White House was he
racist sure everybody was back then I
mean there were slavery in Columbus put
a piece of [ __ ] you know but also well
but everybody back then yes there was
European hegemony and there was the idea
that we with you know there was the all
bad a lot of bad ideas out there eight
of them including leaching including
things like leaching including things
like well you've got bad spirits in your
body so you can keep going all the way
back King Tut
don't go to King Tut's tomb because he
had slaves we can just keep going back
and all the way back
so if the slippery road of course it is
it and also when you desecrate a federal
Monument its she's supposed to ten years
in jail if you really want to get rid of
it there's a process there's a legal
process to go through it it's like how
far you want to go back what that woman
dumped some women Hannah like the
Confederate flag and stuff yeah dad I
get that I do too I never like to but
you know and then that that she does
that she's a stand-up comic and I
watched her special on that who's this
and none that she's Hannah what's her
name
he gets me yeah and she said because she
would never him in the name of this that
the her special wasn't in that I think I
don't know so she said she was caught
I'm telling you saying that Picasso was
Picasso he's a Picasso all she was
calling oh he's an [ __ ] and his work
should be sort of dismissed was the
argument because he was terrible to
women and terrible to be a terrible guy
but no no no he's a great artist it
doesn't mean that his art should be you
know and Picasso was a giant of a
painter now she was an art historian but
they did you know not even her she
studied art history but you can't just
dismiss some of these work completely
it's not up to you you to cancel someone
like that go [ __ ] yourself
cuz you're next if you're gonna have
that kind of a world you will be next
you will be next they're coming for you
next if you behave that way it's just
not the way to make the world better we
get Jimmy Kimmel exactly Jimmy Kimmel
was part of the culture it canceled
culture man got a lot of people
cancelled then finally Jimmy did he had
a lot of stuff going on when then people
went hold on hold up dude and they start
looking he he's funny and making fun of
people so his job is to be satirical
about it I don't think he's canceling to
like [ __ ] you know second chances are
you know I mean you look into it be
really yes that makes me so sad
dammit ah we have lost our minds yes I
agree I listen I don't think you should
be canceled her stuff he did you know
that old the Carmel own stuff and when
he was doing a rap song with Snoop Dogg
used the n-word that's not what you
cancelled no and I'm saying if you if
you're gonna if you're gonna be a
proponent of canceled
it's gonna come back around - it's gonna
come back around but also things work
differently but everybody's moving in
we're trying to figure this out you know
that they're there I'm old enough to
remember where things were so different
when gay marriage was considered
outrageous with I'm old enough to
remember when when the idea that you two
gay people could raise a kid instead of
being in foster care was outrageous and
I believe that I was like no that's you
can't have that and then a woman who had
two gay parents argued me into like a
different point of view I didn't know
I'd never met barely met any gay people
until I was in theater school I didn't
[ __ ] know I had stereotypical ideas I
was and I I'm not was I'm not dumb but I
was young and I was [ __ ] the ignorant
but I've changed my mind
that's possible you can become a better
[ __ ] person and you should be allowed
to become a better person like it's just
like you know with Jimmy Fallon you also
talked about a different time when June
when Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy Kimmel do
anything should time a different time
yeah again how far do you want to go
back do you want to get rid of all uh
you know John Wayne movies because you
know but the corporations are
corporations are are literally getting
rid of people and that's what's so scary
it's it's it's that they're just like
saying you can't work anymore what is he
supposed to do what the [ __ ] is he
supposed to do he did it on your network
or whatever it was
hey you know I I just I mean it doesn't
make the world a better place this
behavior it does not it does not it
doesn't you're just full of [ __ ] and
it's me I'm Carla hits the nail on the
head because you know because he's not
part of a major Network you know he says
krola about the net effect of blackface
on black americans they should look at
everything in context what is going on
we're gonna have to start speaking about
difference between what the intent
intent is you know it's funny like there
he goes was there a noose hanging bubble
what wallace's garage yes there was was
a meant for him note was it it was
actually for the rain right so let's
play so you could say there's a there's
a noose there yeah we freaked out
and let's cancel NASCAR now let's cancel
this and make Bubba Wallace the hero
yeah was there news if you just look at
the headlines yes was it there as a car
garage and they all have hopes yes yeah
so in its again it it's it it's
conscious but of course its context its
contest and its intention what was your
context what was your intention if you
take that away you're a [ __ ] idiot
and they're coming for you next and
nobody wants to live in a world like
that and I don't it has to be fought
against has to be voiced against it is
it is madness
this is the madness of crowds look bit
up the madness to be here's when you say
crowds remember one in fifty people are
on Twitter you're right but Bubba the
corporation's listen to these [ __ ]
people that corporations like like these
big corporations get rid of people
because they it's about their bottom
line and they're they're not they're not
behaviorally even yeah I will say in
1950 1960 1970 and even in 1980 and
maybe beginning in 1990 if you were
found out to be gay at your workplace
you could be fired you would have your
life ruined you could have so so there
are a lot of this stuff is now a push in
the opposite direction but human beings
love to beat ran a call and they love to
do this but it used to be that being gay
was illegal and used to be that being
gay was dangerous dude you used to be
the being gay was a liability 100% dude
you know when we're gonna have to get
the [ __ ] out of LA I hope this does I
hope this
I hope this dude brats in [ __ ] jail
if that cop who kneeled on George
Floyd's neck if they find him innocent I
don't know how they would yeah the world
would be on fire yeah I know that some
of the other cops could get their jobs
back there's some day well yeah cuz the
label I mean yeah but but cuz they
didn't do dil due process with them they
just fired him off the bat yeah anytime
they do that I think 9 out of 10 cops
who that's happened before it got their
jobs back that's a different story
if the homeboy who kneeled on his neck
if he can prove you know somehow I don't
know what they're gonna do I think he's
dead to rights [ __ ] if they somehow
family minutes it you think the Rodney
King stuff was riots Oh Bubba I'm gonna
get on a boats gonna mill the ocean well
the world set
fire yeah we've got to get out yeah you
got to get out we'd have in the middle
of you do we'd have to uh everyone have
to get out I mean I gotta get a pilot
imagine what would happen and B III
don't see that I don't see I'm just
saying in a weird world that we live in
I'd be nuts yeah but the jury has to
know come on you know but you know yeah
I mean come on you remember after the
Rodney King verdict and then OJ was on
trial afterwards and they said they made
sure the oj did not get convicted yeah
afterwards even though he's guilt they
were very very afraid of he was always
guilty of yes yes hmm
yeah well say there's some us thinking
about the other day I'm like what if you
know yeah sometimes prosecution [ __ ]
you get his process you look at the you
know the guy defending him it's like
they try to find an impartial jury right
they try to find a jury that bolts up a
story they do find them they'll find
people that just like they'll find some
obscure mathematician there's like I
don't read their what and that's who
they want they want an impartial jury
you can't have somebody who's from the
same community that's why they tell
that's nice they move trials out of the
town cuz you can't get out like you
would pop culture and it's all like a
life of it if your adjourn to not
convict your Fox oh dude so you gotta
wear like a [ __ ] you know you got to
be anonymous but a lot of times I'll try
to find you no no the entire world to be
on fire if they somehow mess if the
prosecution messes this up and he gets
off you ever sit on a jury
no I did attempted murder jury was it
fun no but it was very unsecure things
to how things hinged on one little
factor we need everybody hands on warmly
on one u-turn yeah but these guys were
really dangerous they had shot a I saw
the gun that shot it wasn't it wasn't a
pistol it was a [ __ ]
modified air he lied you talk about the
details of the murder yeah I think so
it's all public record that they they
tried wasn't asked to do it if I do I
hope it's something really cool yeah
they made like this I was on TV at the
time so yes I was on TV and I said I
need a sidebar I said Your Honor I'm I'm
an actor and I don't if these guys are
very dangerous gang
if I convict these guys and he goes
judge goes listen man if they're like me
I've never seen you before
[Laughter]
they're like me I never I never heard if
I don't worry about oh my gosh Phil huh
I was like what I was like that Hard
Rock Casino guy no way here nobody here
ever nobody around here ever heard you
alright yeah okay all right so a city in
eastern China is introduced tea is
introducing a new system in place where
anyone who intends to get married can go
and give their driver's license and then
information about their spouse and see
if their spouse has any sort of domestic
abuse cases against them that's apparent
feel like every wish is that you have to
come in oh okay that's fair okay more
right I'm like do you have any steroids
I want to get thick um I feel like
you're uber I should do that for god
sakes mm-hmm
trying to be as domestic abuse I woke up
to my husband's fist well that's not
good goddamn yes people will be allowed
to do this twice every year is there a
lot of domestic violence in China feel
like guys like during a lot nacho there
yeah that's what they were saying during
the lockdown there were a lot of
instances where domestic abuse went
wrong and then don't get Brian every day
every day every day
gonna hit him slap you around yeah but I
just counter it'll come back right blink
twice if you need help oh we can't cuz
this done my lips dumped my this don't
work you don't move you can't pick good
news mattes they look great a bad news
is you can't blink just sleep with your
eyes open some people sleep with their
eyes oh my sister oh that's so me and my
man my buddy my buddy came up and we're
looking at my sister and she was like
this so you've been my buddy goes
Kathleen
yeah man yes
and he started walking back downstairs
and bumped in me is this creepy man I
don't want to how'd that happen they
just the retina shuts off I wouldn't
dream it no knowing her she was probably
at her eyes that one just [ __ ]
looking at her for no reason
grace what else yet okay so Sasha Baron
Cohen actually crashed a right-wing
rally it was the March for our lives
three and what he ended up doing was he
became a sponsor for this rally last
minute and he did it under like some
sort of disguise he said that he was
someone else was afoot for his show
again he's gonna show us show time
oh yeah hilarious oh so good I'm not
sure if it's gonna be for a show or not
but good you have to love Sasha Baron
Cohen he managed to get a bunch of races
to a racist sing-along yeah he's so
funny there was a band performing and he
once the band left he actually got
dressed to look just like the singer
from that band so he went back on stage
and asked me for a show and people
thought that it was the band's lead
singer coming on to do like an encore
and he starts singing about how Hillary
Clinton belongs in prison and the
Chinese gave everyone the Wuhan flu he
was started singing alone and halfway
through that racist he said a couple
other things apparently but halfway
through people finally started to catch
on and they wanted to get him off of the
stage but he hired his own security team
that didn't allow anyone to take him off
the stage and he had an ambulance
waiting for him in the wings to
basically help him leave
[Applause]
[Applause]
scare the lady Jesus Chris wh oh [ __ ]
the WHL but yeah that's what he did over
the weekend yeah I mean you know I don't
know yeah and this is a little update
yesterday night governor Gavin Newsom
has officially closed down all bars in
the LA area
dude calm restore it not open any time
soon
hmm no bad news again when do we start
looking at deaths of course there's more
cases you're gonna be more case yeah
yeah more two more weeks of this event
how about this cam Natan signing with
the England Patriots New England
Patriots this is huge man [ __ ] yeah
Jesus really big and what's interesting
is now I'm sure people rooted for him
but he's kind of a get you made me a ton
of money who's MVP in 2014 I think 215
so he's a stud but he's taking more hits
than any other quarterback than a fan oh
yeah so he said like these injuries I
didn't know that yeah but he's signed
with New England and it's basically it's
a one-year deal all off incentives so if
he plays well he get paid so I feel like
people got a really root form now right
smart move right obvious it's does he um
31 psych based on me that's your glory
years that's your glory he can
technically play another seven eight
years no not with his playing stop but
but he why cuz you just get retakes he's
had so much injury really a good three
years for sure Wow and I guess Richard
Sherman's not happy with how much he's
making right now do one year he'll pay
the veteran correct more than 1 million
he could earn up to 7 million incentives
well here's thing no one had wanted to
you know take a risk on him because he
has he had like he had foot surgery at a
knee surgery and he's been beat up so
the Patriots doing what the Patriots do
they signing like they've done a fourth
Randy Moss
Corey Dillon I you know what check I
would imagine bouncing will protect him
with his line with the his offensive
scheme right I mean they try yeah
and then Sherman posted how many former
League MVPs assigned for the league
minimum asked for our friend just
ridiculous
transcendent talent and less-dense
cubies again 15 so why did he why did he
say yes to it because he wants to play
for them no well no that's about it no
one's picking him up at all what the
[ __ ] I'm amazed what because of his
injuries because they feel like he's I
don't know for whatever was maybe bit
like his attitude injuries damn
Sherman's right but also it shows you
how bad can didn't want to play cuz I
bet you Colin Kaepernick went sign for
him for that deal that's amazing I would
have thought he'd sign for a hundred and
fifty million dollars or something Jesus
no Jesus
oh he I'd imagine he's got a lot of
money in the bank as it is you would
hope yeah
what is she good this Egyptian belly
dancer has been sentenced to three years
in prison because of her social media
posts I guess they're goddamn yeah
Wow the [ __ ] Egyptian rules are you know
hey it could we could be living in Egypt
yeah yeah Here I am complaining I'll
we're headed that way tell you what
yeah Jesus Christ yeah three years four
years is something seductive on
Instagram desert answer just 3 million
followers by the way ok I just didn't
see anything crazy but you know rules
are different there whoa got every
Instagram thought in LA would well screw
di was rather cosmopolitan but they have
now there is this this sort of Islamic
fundamentalist sort of movement that
they become a lot more she's maybe she
took him down and it's more possibly and
then she also said that um someone got a
hold of her pictures and probably posted
him it wasn't think it was three years
in prison and like a huge fine - they
even said there was a tik-tok user like
a 17 year old tic-tock user that was
crying and talking about being
gang-raped they censor her to prison
yeah because of her talking about it
it's like any moral self advice pray
about moving ignorances egypt or taxes
oh I'll take you know I'm gonna take a
Texas oh yeah take Texas wow I'm gonna
take our way take anywhere yeah
all right this other one he said this
guy's a barista over at Starbucks in San
Diego and then so one woman kind of just
came of a middle finger and then she
threw a tantrum because he wouldn't
serve her because it wasn't she wasn't
wearing a mask so then she goes oh yeah
so she actually posted about it on her
Facebook thinking people are gonna be on
her side
oh he's on your side and then uh I'll
show you this right now
rules are rules that's her that was her
post you're fine
me Lennon from Starbucks who refused to
serve me because I'm not wearing a mask
next time I'll wait for cops and bring
him up she never put him on blast the
kids doing his [ __ ] job yeah doesn't
make the rules that's her - she said
she's a jerk why doing this so someone
made a phony ID count for the boy and
it's already over $90,000 [ __ ] people
suck and now she wants a portion of the
GoFundMe money like she said she's
dealing with let me see at last check
that GoFundMe page is up more than
$22,000 Kyle says she wants a chunk of
that money and is threatening to sue the
page creator for defamation thank you we
saw yeah God wouldn't what a [ __ ] you
she's terrible
no she what's the matter she has she was
a portion of the money I never
threatened them and I said she says
she's getting too obviously getting
threatened probably Shanta Brewster
who's doing this job yeah hit listen if
you're me that'd be better governor
Newsom be mad at [ __ ] you never started
the corona virus don't be mad I would
love to talk to news in my Betty Lou
like if we listened to him he'd be like
I'm getting 15 different stories from 15
different people I don't know how I
would be political it's yeah do you feel
better yeah there you go
that wasn't that long no I've never done
it it no less than that way this check
this couple up there was a protest at
Central West End at st. Louis Missouri
and then I guess some protesters broke
into the it's like a private area right
probably private
property there's a private road and then
there's a gate right there right yeah so
as soon as they were welcomed by the the
protesters walking by them the guy had a
rifle on the girl and gun and they're
just kinda like I'd be the same way I'd
be exactly the exact same way those
protesters come in American it's our
property yeah her property and if you
bunch protesters come on your property
there where they burn [ __ ] and stuff
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you guys that's their
property yeah you come near my house I'd
shoot you too I don't blame there you go
they're both lawyers to you by the way
well it's their home is that their home
yes sir home and these [ __ ]
it's like a very upscale area but it's
also a gated community right yeah
so they got into the game Roby I be
right there with my gun come on my shoe
even of these containers Utama a
different animal if they start looting
personal private it's dangerous and what
if you have your kids in there look I
don't trust that's good there and they
throw a Molotov cocktail also no there's
no there's no talking I'm having my
ar-15 that's right and you pass my gate
you're getting lit the [ __ ] up I agree
that's how you have to do I agree a
hundred percent what am I gonna wait for
it to see if you guys are friendly fire
or the [ __ ] out of here no dude and
guess what I'm pretty cool about things
imagine if you're doing that in Texas or
other areas where people don't give a
[ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
come coming miles Larry the sniper let
me know that goes for you try to set
fire to my house see what I do
mm-hmm I'm sure bums are trying with
their [ __ ] that's America right there so
it's not about being race I don't know
if that's America there no I'm saying
you can't just do it to people's that's
terrifying
yeah got a bunch of people with but what
what they do but I'm sorry why did they
go after their house did the lady do
something the mayor of that town that
the protesters wants to reside our
resigned lives nary uh so they pass by
this person's house yep this one is
about NBA possibly allowing players to
replace their last name on their jersey
with the social business message that's
fine if you start NBA NFL back I don't
care if you put
big dicks across their face okay let's
get Carl ever you guys will want to do
I'm with it man yeah whatever you want
to do cool just get it back
we could play naked if they want do I'm
sure more people would watch that bronze
build dangling flap around your face
um one of the sponsors of the show whoop
this is a pro golfer Nick Watney and
apparently he was able to find out the
head kovat because of the lot oh yeah
whoa whoa because it should reported
this your latest our piano to rent is
significantly but significantly above
your typical range oh wow
it might be a sign of illness Wow
whoop is no joke oh yeah respiratory
rate like performance savings ever sent
ours worse I gotta get a whoop I gotta
get a whoop and that's pretty well it's
nuts right yeah yeah
that's really cool man it's pretty cool
and then just a quick one here that guy
you were talking about before that
insane picture he got a jeep fully
Kevlar and it's got six wheel it cops
insane who is that guy we just played on
picture look like USB we thought he was
really really tall but he wasn't he a
song for Jack that's the picture if
those alone whatever I say cops
when you get something you cop something
you actually ghetto cops ah that's well
you know that's weird lingo I'll give
you that branch yeah no I'm sorry that
is weird the classic ass down though
that's really cool and I think that's
about it well I know the kind of Jeep I
want now how about this one real quick
oh dude
Mexico City oh gee all this was crazy
it's insane how they came out of a 50
caliber rifle that came out of sniper
rifles guns grenades all sorts of stuff
they feel a big deal them nope but two
people in a security does I had men with
high-caliber weapons yeah it is crazy
there I cannot murder cartel yeah oh
what cartel yeah he does the police cars
are highly strongly so let's go let's go
cuz there's the the Zeta they had help
from the Americans and we really [ __ ]
them up and just dispatched oh yeah but
so it's always now it's another group
yeah
and they let him get out of hand in and
then the mayor
against Cummings like dude all right
yeah well the Mexican Marines are no
joke either
they've got oh they've got all their
stuff - oh yeah you know Wow damn you
shot in the collarbone I'm the older the
knee that sucks if you're gonna try to
more energy than ever
what's that says he has more energy than
ever
probable drug cartels make use trying to
assassinate these top cops organization
and years long work between the
government organized crime if you're
gonna do that to the city's top cops you
just declared war completely and told us
what they do though and holos go cartel
has become public enemy number one
mm-hmm attack by space 28 gun mill
gunman sniper rifles grenades were
confiscated 28 arrested 12 suspects 12
19 retained Jesus Christ man yeah but I
got season I got a clear war on anybody
hmm yeah Mexico is just they got their
issues yep
not good Dallas guess where I'll be
Addison July 16 17 18 come see me I'm
excited get your tickets tea fat K comm
Salt Lake City wise guys July 16th
through the 18th 18th the first thick
boy bike club ride sign up at fake boy
ride at gmail.com for all details
information Spokane Washington July 30th
through August 1st August 1st our second
fake boy bike club ride sign up a thick
boy ride at gmail.com Irvine is end of
August I don't know why it's just 1 21
on there we gotta fix that
Irvine end of August Tampa and Austin
come up as well get tickets at t5k calm
fake boy mark should get a watts hot we
got new [ __ ] dropping for the summer as
well stay tuned take boy calm that it be
that's here buddy this the finala kid
route